[Applause]
so
so basically um uh governor cuomo
looks like he might be out of here i
don't think he's going
it's just you know the rules you broke
them but it's also not shocking to me
that he's like nah i'm not leaving i
didn't think was that bad
yeah i i mean i think that if he takes
that stance
if he just goes yeah i was just being
like a charming old guy i didn't realize
it was making them feel uncomfortable
now i get it
but like i honestly i and i'm not trying
to cap for the [ __ ] cuomo's like he's
a piece of [ __ ] for killing all the old
people
100 he's not even a piece of [ __ ] for
killing all the old people he's a piece
of [ __ ] for killing all the old people
hiding it and then writing a book about
how great a job he did yes
if he never wrote the book and he never
hit it and he just took accountability
for it he was like listen we didn't know
where to put these [ __ ] we got
to put them somewhere where you want to
put them on the [ __ ] streets they're
going to die too
if he just said something like that i
think we'd understand but to write the
book
about what a great job you did didn't he
hide the numbers wasn't it the numbers
he specifically lied about
that's where it's also like now you're
just trying to be president and this is
your little [ __ ] moves [ __ ] you
so interesting thing happened is uh
biden administration
drops the investigation yeah on cuomo
for the old people
yeah right i mean it was just taking out
old [ __ ]
yeah he drops the investigation well he
let biden live so he was like all right
i'm good
where was he bringing back he's like
[Laughter]
so but but there's still
a department of justice investigation
that's going on from i think this woman
named leticia james
right but that's a new york based
investigation so i'm like why the [ __ ]
would they drop the government one
that's weird
right like the federal government won
and um
maybe and i'm not exactly sure but maybe
the reason was if he's found guilty of
the federal crime
the state would need to pay
the victims so that could be a massive
lawsuit
with an already constricted budget oh
[ __ ] so maybe
on some democrats rubbing shoulder [ __ ]
like let's not take this out in the
state
if he did something [ __ ] up why don't
we just let them handle it internally
now i don't know who ends up paying
i don't know who ends up paying the
victims families if he gets convicted of
the department of justice the
local the new york one maybe that's a
personal one right maybe his decisions
so maybe he'll have to personally pay
for it i don't know maybe the state
still has to but i'm looking for some
reason why they would let him off the
hook and then just yesterday buying out
here just like i think he should resign
yeah that makes sense what is that about
yeah i don't know like i was trying to
read through like what exactly he did
and part of me feels like they had this
information on him for a while
yeah i mean like like i feel like a
sexual harassment case if someone's been
in politics for mad long like
i think it's fairly easy to build i
don't know maybe i'm like cynical but
like
a man in a position of power like i feel
like you talk to people for a living
yeah like i feel like you could build a
case against a guy especially if he was
like how long has he been in politics
for
50 years and was he propositioning these
women that's another thing i need to
understand because like
the sexual harassment thing is is tricky
because
you could think of sexual harassment and
he could be ain't nothing sexual about
that
i think some of them according to the
new york times article were like
i want you to come suck my dick in the
bathroom i think it was like like
groping
yeah and i'm again i'm not
[ __ ] them chimp nipple sauce monkeys
[ __ ] them i'm just trying to understand
is putting your hand on a woman's back
as
you guys leave the room is that sexual
harassment
because he might think how do i get her
out of my office i got [ __ ] to do
maybe if i guide her out of the office i
don't want this woman around
i got old people to kill let me just get
the [ __ ] out right we got so many old
people they're still alive yeah we need
to do something
that's a big problem let me just guide
this lady out of the office
sometimes people are tactile and it's a
thing of endearment it's like hey
i want to let you know how close i am
it's kind of what he's saying exactly
and he's probably like i'm so
comfortable
in who i am you don't got to worry
about me sexually harassing you if he's
straight up asking for dick sucks
that's different so there's that he was
kicking crazy game okay go so
this is one of them from new york times
and i say crazy maybe in a bad way he's
like mom you're going to suck it or not
yeah if he was doing some dip session he
was on some dipsticks if he was on some
dips that [ __ ] then that's different
yeah
he says this is from new york times
article the governor leaned in close to
her cheek and said
i'm going to say i see a spider on your
shoulder
investigators found then he brushed his
hand in the area between
her shoulder and breast oh that's whack
i thought he was going to shoot a web on
her shoulder
i'm just saying bro like you said
there's a spider on your shoulder she's
like what you're just like
i thought that's what he was gonna do i
was like yo this guy kind of creative
old spider-man ass [ __ ]
okay go go uh it's like another one so
he touched titty
i think so yeah there's an accusation
that he grew up with yeah
just before what if there was a spider
you know women don't like the was on he
said the spider was on her shoulder so
even if
he would have to say hey spider's on
your titty and then [ __ ] that's the
odd way to get the spider off is just
grab it
you never didn't brush it you never
grabbed the spider like that
you never should do it
that's crazy did you never try to do
that what do you use to get spiders off
of things your lips and your tongue
no you got what you do i punch them you
punch it
there's a spider on you oh you budget i
just slapped it with my
dick so that's what he's doing
what's wrong with you guys there was a
spider and i tried to brush it off with
my [ __ ] and ball
why wouldn't you guys do it how do you
guys clean spiders off of women's tits
and shoulders sounds like a man
okay so before is this sounding totally
reasonable i don't understand
why fox news is getting so crazy about
this guy's just wiping spiders off of
women's children
exactly so in december 2018 just before
posing for a picture with a male member
of the private detail and his wife at a
holiday party oh he's sexually harassing
dudes mr cuomo peeled off the woman's
name tag
just below her breast the governor began
to leave the report said before doubling
back
handed the man the name tag saying
something to the effect of
you might want this i could get in
trouble so they're claiming
that that's also wow that's a stretch is
that like
is that like a memento like is that like
some corporate way of like getting used
panties
like does he you know like you know how
muffin creeps the lamest way ever
the lame like hello my name is sarah
i'm gonna go shoot some webs to this
later but there's a couple that
is that that's not maybe he's so
progressive like he saw that there was a
gender on her name tag and he was like
let's get that out of here like gender
is fluid now
you know yeah it was mr and mrs but that
could be they it could be him her
maybe he just really wants to remember
her name you think about that that's
another thing
let me look at like a flash card
memorize it here take this i don't want
my wife to think i'm disappointed
this is you said it was a long time ago
right maybe he's saving the name because
he's gonna kill her grandma
maybe it's like i need to make sure i
save all the names of the grandmas that
i'm gonna kill
i'll put it up on a wall this is great
potentially yeah okay good the guy's
organized
there might be worse ones though okay go
go what else you got i don't know i'm
trying
so far i mean it seems like what he's
either let me throw his dick on girl's
shoulders to get buggers a sex
proposition and a grope
i mean we're taking off a details name
tag you know what i mean
i mean why would she place her name tag
there
a strange old italian man i think she's
asking crap at all before like
it's clearly her decision right it's not
the creepy old italian piece of [ __ ]
that's just touching her titty as he
takes off name tag it's the woman's
fault
for having a name how dare you why would
she ever have a name
bro why would she ever ever name and
then try to tell people her name it's
disgusting broad
yeah bro that's how italians wanted
exactly he was furious
right charlatan
yeah okay it's disgusting that she would
show up to this corporate event as a
woman and feel like she should have some
form of identity trying to tell people
her name
like why are you flirting you know what
he probably saw her and he was like oh
my god this woman's trying to act like
she was invited to the meeting when we
all know that she's here to clean up
afterwards
takes the name tag off so she can do
what she's supposed to do
this is this is ann gave back to the
husband he's like yo your wife's out of
place yo
she is out of place you want people to
know her name y'all don't got anything
to cook yeah
yeah this is [ __ ] up she's flirting
okay she was flirting he's looking out
for the husband
he's trying to keep marriages together
camaraderie camaraderie
here's another one try to rationalize
this may 2017 a woman working for an
energy group i'm talking
2017.
he was a kid bro he's a kid he was a
young guy he was a 65 year old kid right
like you made a mistake your limitations
where is the statue of limitations i
need to go visit guys
yo where is the statue it's a memorial
of limitations the memorial limitations
[ __ ] down right y'all was taking down
george washington you want to take down
a statue of limitations
that one [ __ ] up a lot more people son
[ __ ] that statue
all right so in 2017 virginia 2017 and
2015. those are
completely different 2017. defense
this woman encounter mr cuomo on a rope
line at a conservation event
i don't know what a rope line is sorry i
know we got an idea i don't know so
that's it
they used to call that [ __ ]
he lynching out of lynching in 2017 bro
yeah this woman wants to make it about
her
you gotta go you got it right they she
wants to make it about her
but there was literally human beings
mark yeah i know okay
and she thinks she's the one that's got
it worse in that scenario
it's despicable it has to be a white
woman gotta be a wife it has to be a
white woman
what [ __ ] cat some [ __ ] character
trying to make the lynching about her
and it was in virginia her name is
virginia
oh my goodness that's on purpose holy
[ __ ] he probably went down there stopped
the lynching
he went down there to stop the lynching
bro literally the person's about to get
lynched he just starts seeing spiders
all over their shoulders and chest
and he's like i'm gonna shoot something
on help you slip off you slip up off
that rope real quick
you want to protect the spiders you
don't want to kill a spider because he's
a conservative what are you doing
on the way to saving lives all right
yeah so she wore a shirt bearing her
employer's name
the clan probably quote when the
governor reached mrs limiatus
he reached he ran two fingers across her
chest pressing down
on each of the letters as he did so
reading out the name of the energy
company as he went
okay first of all was it in braille
was it in braille if it was he's older
it's hard to see
he might have astigmatism i got a
stigmatizer he might not have his
bifocals they didn't come in just yet
and maybe it was in braille
the guy's obviously fluent in braille
right because that's how he communicates
to all those old people he's about to
murder that they're gonna
be dead right so he knows it well
he got it down and he was just reading
the braille yeah he just wants to buy a
shirt for his wife i want to see what
company this is
or maybe raising his fingers you know
when you're a child you go like that try
to stay
he's a here he's a kid he's a young kid
he's a young italian kid
yeah son this is crazy bro it's a real
witch hunt dog
it's a real witch that was the same
woman as the spider incident that was
the same one
i got to see her
this shirt around her like the
guaranteed sexual harassment bra
something like that there's money to be
made out here
um and then the last one i can see here
is that uh he could do his own bidding
as in his aggressive flirtations with
the female trooper instructing her don't
tell anyone about
our conversations so maybe he told her
like
some government secrets yeah i'm killing
a lot of old people right now yeah
don't tell anyone i'm gonna get your dad
out the old people home
don't tell anybody because the rest of
them are dying
um we don't know what he said to her
don't tell anybody about a little
conversation why does she say what was
said
yep she doesn't want to say because he
told her not to say
but why are you saying yeah she's
snitching she's snitching but she's not
willing to snitch about the goods maybe
he's
giving her some good information you
know maybe he was saying that
you know he was going to make a contract
with all the people of new york state
and then break it immediately
and then have us mask up just to go
inside stores and restaurants again
piece of [ __ ]
the santas never did that desantis never
did that never did anything wrong to
santa's name
here as nobody my man sucking dick out
there like a [ __ ] hero who's sucking
dick desantis
god bless him you know i mean bless him
i love that desantis like i just grabbed
much
there's a spider on your dick
sorry sir all right guys we're gonna
take a break from this exclusive patreon
clip because some of y'all need a
cleaner option for your
nicotine consumption okay we're all
adults here some of us choose to use
nicotine to relax focus or just unwind
after a long day
lucy nicotine is a company that was
created to help
nicotine users find a cleaner option and
feel better about the ways that they
consume nicotine their latest product
is slim nicotine pouches which contain
pure synthetic nicotine and
provide the same satisfaction that
nicotine users expect
okay without any tobacco at all get rid
of that [ __ ] tobacco
all right lucy slim pouches use the
newest technology for synthesizing pure
nicotine
in the lab none of the tobacco all the
nicotine satisfaction lucy slim pouches
include both
coconut oil and gum base to provide a
soft fluffy texture
that enhances the flavor and doesn't dry
out your mouth they come in three
strengths
four eight and 12 milligrams and three
exclusive and delicious flavors
spearmint mango
and cool cider okay uh akash what else
we have to tell them listen
i don't smoke but you got a family
member you got a friend who uses
nicotine products
just have them use this instead it just
makes the most sense honestly it's gonna
be better for them it's gonna be better
for their health and they're actually
gonna
enjoy it way more so it's 20 21 don't
compromise when you're choosing your
nicotine products go with the newest
tobacco-free options from lucy
and here's the beautiful thing okay if
you go to lucy.co and use the promo code
flagrant
you're going to get 20 off your order of
lucy slim pouches or
any other lucy products okay that's lucy
l-u-c-y
dot c-o and use the promo code flagrant
at checkout
also i have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains
non-tobacco nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical
lucy.co and be sure to use that problem
called flagrant now let's get back to
this exclusive patreon
we are we getting vaccinated the proof
of vaccine what's going on with all that
[ __ ]
it's looking a little scary looking a
little sussy out there yeah
yeah so what do you think yeah so let's
break down what the rules are what's
going on what's happened in new york a
lot of people like oh y'all moving out
of new york again
no we vex baby we good we backs they did
not pass down the mask mandate which is
what i was worried about
they didn't pass out of mass mandate but
every store is now mandating mess
oh i haven't seen that yet oh yo son if
you go out you're gonna start to see all
these stores you know you gotta wear a
mask especially
like in [ __ ] in in my neighborhood a lot
of the stores really yeah
yeah neighborhoods sure oh yeah i
haven't seen that yet so i think that's
what's basically gonna happen like
where my girl is doing her like um
where she works basically uh the office
now has a mass mandate she works
but for how like how long are we doing
this though even if she's backs
even if your vax if your vacs when you
get to your desk you can take off your
mask
wait if it backs when you get to that oh
yeah so like a restaurant yeah
oh okay but that should stop the
restaurants right i haven't even carried
around a mask
for a minute this performative nonsense
this whole like
i'm gonna go to a restaurant and have my
mask until i get to the dinner table and
then we're gonna eat and drink and laugh
and yell
with no mask on right next to each other
it's just just
cut that [ __ ] out a restaurant is gonna
start putting up the dividers and [ __ ]
like that again
i like that i ain't got fries i wanna
hear nobody's conversation next to me i
want you to get better food to me
i want you no get out of here block that
[ __ ] out you like being next
[ __ ] yeah i like
looking at their table and like just
eavesdropping and seeing what's going on
and [ __ ] like that and then making up
coming up with a whole story about
about their life that [ __ ] is fun you
ever go out to dinner with someone else
you or you usually eat alone
alone come on
i'm not even listening to his date bro
his date is
he's developing all scenarios with the
people next door
that's crazy you're a wild boy for that
um
so la county washington dc have recently
introduced mass requirements i think
vegas did that
uh louisiana did so on monday as did san
francisco
several surrounding northern california
counties uh de blasio made a different
calculation you want to focus on vaccine
rates
concerning requiring everyone to wear
mass it would remove the incentive for
people considering vaccinated uh
being vaccinated is is law um
we heard i think you guys said as we sat
down that they are going to make in
schools
kids seven to twelve is that 12 to 17 12
12 to 17
get vaccinated what are you guys
thoughts on that i don't like that
there's not enough mortality amongst
children to say you should get a vaccine
let me throw this at you
and i want to hear your reaction to this
kids have to because this is what a lot
of people are going to say right that a
pro
pro super pro vaccine is kids have to be
vaccinated to go to school anyway
what's the difference with this one what
is your pushback mortality rates for
smallpox for
[ __ ] measles all that [ __ ] was very
high for kids right right this is not
killing kids right
so y'all get vacs as adults take care of
yourself
don't put that [ __ ] on kids i think i
don't think it should be law period
necessarily but
don't have kids doing that i think
that's reasonable b
i think that's right now the the
pushback that someone's going to give is
well the delta variant
can still uh infect you even if you've
been vaccinated
so we don't want this is what they're
going to say yeah we don't want the kids
to get this delta variant and then pass
it on to
a more vulnerable staff member at the
school
who might die if you are vexed and the
death rate for vaccinated people even
with delta is less than one percent
yeah if you are that concerned about
getting sick that you're gonna make a
kid get a vaccine
you're a [ __ ] quit your job or don't go
to school like
don't work if you really think that you
could die from it that's okay
and i think we have empathy for those
people who really think that they could
die
even though they are vaccinated they
just think their immune systems are that
weak or they're that over
overweight et cetera but if that's the
case i don't think you make the whole
world been to you
no i think you say i gotta stay home
yeah get a different job go on
employment
do something not that easy though go fam
it's not that easy just get another job
like that
like if that's their career yeah but you
are ace you are such a small fraction of
the population
vaccinating an entire population or just
that person going on unemployment yeah i
mean but it's
not just one person and so like it's the
best
the best argument i've heard for it is
for immuno compromised people
that can't get the vaccine that's the
best so explain that one this is
interesting so there are some
immunocompromised people that
their immune systems are so weak they
can't even get introduced
to the little bit of uh protein strain
that's in the vaccine
so just to clarify real quick this is a
real this is a really interesting point
there are people that are taking
immunosuppressant
drugs because they might have some other
issue maybe they're going through chemo
or maybe they have some sort of cancer
or some other disease they've taken this
drug which really compromised their
immune system
because their immune system is so
compromised they can't even take the
vaccine which is a micro dose
of what the drug is i don't even know if
that's what this vaccine is it might be
a little different
but let's just philadelphia some people
have allergies too to like some of the
stuff in the vaccine so they can't get
it like boom so there are certain people
who
actually can't get vaccinated yeah
should we
be considerate of them should we look
out for them in the same way that we
look out for
people who are crippled right like we
make sure we have ramps
not just steps to get into buildings we
make sure that there's a bathroom for
them
etc just finish what you were saying now
and so because of that
i think that's enough to have everyone
get backs
because it's like we're getting everyone
vexed with certain things like
hep c and all that type of [ __ ] before
you can start certain jobs and that's
not really killing people nowadays but
you still have to get it every 10 years
um for to work at certain places so i'm
like
teacher is one of those public jobs
where i feel like nah you should have to
that's an interesting if it's a public
service job you should it's also
mandated by the state yeah tell me why
i'm callous and where i'm wrong and
thinking that's still too small of a
percentage
to vaccinate an entire population to
what you said earlier we cannot bend
all of legislation to one percent of the
population
probably less well that's really less
that's the conversation
that is happening with corona it's like
what percentage of the population
do you create public policy for yeah
like
the percentage of people who are uh
paralyzed or in wheelchairs or these
types of things
is so small i mean like
it's it's how often do you see people
like on crutches or wheelchair
like and i'm not talking about like
conor mcgregor where he's gonna have it
back
but think about every restaurant is
mandated
yeah that's true to have a wheelchair
bathroom everyone and if they don't have
this because it was grandfathered in
from before
every place of business is mandated
to have some sort of access way for
people that have a wheelchair this is
probably less than one percent of the
population
right but we are making sure that we're
taking care of those people which is
like a really thoughtful
thing to do so this is an interesting
thing with that example specifically
because
those ada accessible buildings they're
like okay we need to make it accessible
so people in wheelchairs and
like handicapable people can get in here
but then with the
like vaccine requirement there's no
caveat for people that can't get
vaccinated
so it's actually just barring them from
entering into businesses
so they're saying like if you can't get
vaccinated there's no
like have caveat to be like oh i have
like a legitimate reason i have a doctor
thing
so they do you know that for sure that's
your fault but do you know that for sure
because i'm pretty sure
as of now that was just from the de
blasio thing which i think will get like
tweaked over time oh okay but as of now
there's no like caveat for them
because i'm pretty sure like if you're
not allowed to get the vaccine due to
you just have to show like negative
coverage yes i i imagine that's right
because the negative call of a test gets
you in excelsior pass also i think right
yeah
and i think like an antigen test will
get you one for like two weeks or
something like that right
right yeah so yeah so it's tricky but it
is interesting just like public policy
wise is
what percentage of the population has to
be affected for us to change public
policy because if it was 50
we would change public policy if it's
old people
right like old people i don't know what
percentage old people make up in america
maybe
25 or something like that that was
enough for us to go maybe it's
15 who knows but that was enough for us
to go you know what we can't let old
people die
we are going to change our lives we're
going to shut down businesses because
we want our old people we love our
parents we love our grandparents we
don't want these [ __ ]
15 is over 15 so like that's
15 we know yeah one percent will we
change it
i don't think we will i think for one
percent
we're not going to change it unless
there is a massive financial benefit
yes for an incredibly powerful
corporation in america i don't know
and i think that's the big pharma i
think big pharma has enough i think it's
other businesses too like this is like
the biggest wealth transfer in
history like what people are saying i
don't know how true that is but like
there's a lot of people that are getting
richer
from covet and lockdowns and
restrictions in general i think it's all
about popular sentiment
if it becomes popular for everybody to
get vaxxed like
trans bathrooms some places less than
one percent
but yeah genderless bathrooms just
because it became a popular topic
i think that's all basically sorry real
quick going back to your i keep thinking
about your handicap example because
that's a great point
one thing i'm thinking is that's for a
business if you decide to have a
business you have to have an ada
accessible whatever
we don't tell every individual homeowner
your house has to have
a wheelchair accessible ramp so i think
that's where i
am finding the parallel with vaccine
every individual
has to have a vaccine well they're not
saying every individual has to have
vaccine what they're basically doing is
making it incredibly inconvenient to not
be vaccinated yes
so if your kid wants to go to school you
want your kid to go to school
you want to go eat out at a restaurant
like they're basically taking away all
the luxuries that we enjoy i mean the
only reason that i got vacs is literally
so i could like
quote unquote live my life my life
meaning
i don't want to throw that [ __ ] when i
go on an uber i don't want to throw that
[ __ ] on when i go to a restaurant
i actually want to be a little bit of a
pain in the ass a [ __ ] telling
me to put a mask on on the street
you know what i mean like i want to have
a comeback i ain't got [ __ ] right so i
get bodied on [ __ ]
and to that i would say a lot of that
[ __ ] if people are like hey let me
let me make this choice all right fine
then you also choose not to eat in a
restaurant that's a luxury thing
you choose not to go to a [ __ ]
amusement park or whatever these are
choices
that's you you're choosing and that's
fine like you're using losing these
luxuries
going to school i don't see in the same
way going to school i see
very different if somebody's like hey i
i don't want to get the vax but i don't
want to not be able to go to school
that's different to me than eat at a
restaurant if it's like hey i want to
not forget vax and not wear masks and
eat at restaurants and not [ __ ] you
that's not reasonable but i want to at
least go to school cool
i don't and kids aren't necessarily
affected by this
that's where i'm like i can't
necessarily protect the one percent of
immunocompromised
compromised teachers for this entire
student body
to get a vaccine they probably don't
need they can do uh teaching from home
i mean those teachers can do teaching
from home i think way easier than the
students no
or or getting kids or having a teacher
is a behind the scenes
like you get disability pay all the time
right you get disability we can factor
that into disability payments
also just there's way more workarounds
that killed schools and stuff
yeah it's awesome like one of my buddies
is a teacher at a middle school here and
it's like i mean shift he was in school
a minute ago yeah and like just this is
learning like
test scores went down like literally
like kids are learning to read later
like
but that's what i'm saying it'll
incentivize his parents to get their
kids vexed
right because it's like hey you you see
your child is going to do worse
being at home so i please believe you to
get them back so you can send their ass
to school
please believe parents will put anything
in their kid
to get them out of the house yeah that's
what i'm saying like if all they got to
do
is shove a virus that we don't know what
could happen in 10 years
into their kit to get them to leave the
house five days a week
and not have to pay that's going in that
kid
i think the parents will administer it
themselves that's why i don't like it
like
easily like i can't like if you speak to
i mean you you got well they're like
young but like your sister has a kid
that's super young but like
i'm sure you have friends that have kids
that have the kids at home while they're
trying to work from home
that's fun son they were friends that's
why i don't like it dude you are
essentially forcing
a bunch of kids to get a vaccine it's
kind of coercion a little bit it is
for sure if you want to eat at
restaurants all right man you made the
choice
school is [ __ ] different for kids who
aren't really affected by it it's kind
of
like it's kind of genius be like if you
want everybody in your country to be
vaccinated
yep what you do is you remove the
luxuries and i i kind of believe it
could be a big pharma play off of that
they're not mad at it put it this way
big farm is not matted i think they just
upped the prices of the vaccine i think
johnson johnson and pfizer
and moderna yeah they said the booster
drug dealers just started upping the
price bruh
what up everybody did you enjoy that
expert political analysis on governor
chimp nipple sauce monkey well
if you want more of that actually zero
expertise all flagrancy
why don't you join our patreon we drop a
new episode
every single week every friday that is
exclusive to patreon unfiltered
raw realness i'm telling you it is what
is keeping comedy alive your support
keeps this show available so
go to patreon.com 2 if you want to join
the [ __ ] army we would really
appreciate it
all right we'll see you later